inocap petite finale traité qui se
confiait un jour à son professeur et aux
autres élèves de sa classe
l'histoire vraie d'une petite fille qui
subit des violences voilà comment est
née l'idée de cette comédie musicale en
thème crabe d'actualité sur lequel il
faut continuer à sensibiliser mais ici
c'est avant tout une tranche de vie
terribles d'une enfance oublié
à cette idée de spectacle est né d'une
rencontre une rencontre avec une petite
fille qui a croisé ma route l'année
dernière une petite fille maltraitée et
qui nous a beaucoup émus à la fois moi
et les autres élèves de la classe
sandrine car au professeur des écoles à
l'école élémentaire léman coullier qui
collabore étroitement avec jacques nirlo
professeur d'éducation musicale du
collège hubert de lisle à saint benoît
une réflexion qui a pour principal but
de dénoncer les actes de maltraitance en
direction des enfants
l'affection jumelées on a pu mettre en
place et comédie musicale qui traite de
la maltraitance qui est un sujet très
actuel est toujours actuelle est
malheureusement l'objectif principal de
cette comédie musicale est temps de
dénoncer et de briser le mur du silence
un spectacle composé d'élèves de
primaire de collégiens de lycéens mais
aussi d'adultes et puis il ya le théâtre
la musique la danse autant d'éléments
qui nécessite forcément la présence de
professionnels qui est le plus difficile
c'est l'organisation puisqu'il ya des
écoles qui viennent de partout donc de
saint denis et de l'est donc on
travaille chacun à deux côtés ensuite le
plus difficile c'est tous nous réunir
donc en fait on se réunit à peu près
quatre choix pour monter ce spectacle
jeudi bonnart est un danseur que khaimah
femmes connaissent et sandrine ils m'ont
appelé comme une école de théâtre comme
j'ai négocié à l'école de théâtre et
donc j'ai fait appel à des comédiens à
tous ma troupe de théâtre pour venir
participer à cet événement
des danseurs une chorale et la comédie
musicale peut prendre naissance
la difficulté étant de réunir la troupe
pour les répétitions
mais l'effort a fini par payer puisque
le spectacle a pu se jouer devant un
public et le message est passé
la vie d'une petite fille jouée par une
autre petite fille qui n'a été nullement
impressionnés par l'immense scène du
conservatoire de saint benoît
ouais
l'histoire de pinocchio qui vous est
racontée aujourd'hui c'est quelque part
un hommage à cette petite fille
c'est l'histoire de cette petite est un
projet musical mais surtout éducatif
puisqu'il s'inscrit dans les projets
d'école ou comment sensibiliser les
élèves collégiens lycéens à la
problématique de la maltraitance